herzlichen glückwunsch spd wieder mal
merkels job gerettet und martin schulz
stellen wir fest wird immer mehr zur
tragischen figur bei diesem parteitag
hätte er die rede seines lebens halten
müssen hier die einzige stelle die bei
ihm applaus gekriegt hat ich will an
dieser stelle sagen der markt habe ich
gestern angerufen
[Musik]
weil ich ihn verstehen kann wahnsinn
ja das nennen fachleute einen enden
wollenden applaus beendet haben und
herren gefeiert wurde bei diesem
parteitag in bonn statt dessen andrea
nahles die neue vorsitzende der herzen
sieben minuten schreien für die gruppe
und dann hat sie sich noch den frechen
kleinen kevin diesen juso-vorsitzenden
vorgeknöpft
heute einmal zwerg sein damit morgen
wieder etwas großes rauskommt hat kevin
gesagt was ist das etwas was ist das
etwas große was ist das große was ist
denn etwas großes da sind dafür 10
verdammt noch mal
[Gelächter]
ich glaube ja viele delegierte haben nur
aus angst vor nahles mit ja gestimmt ist
die abgegangen
ist hier abgegangen die frau etwas
großes hermann andrea etwas großes wäre
zum beispiel wenn die spd es schaffen
würde mal wieder ein echter gegenentwurf
zur union zu sein der meldung aus dieser
woche 45 einzelne haushalte besitzen in
deutschland so viel wie die komplette
untere hälfte der bevölkerung das hätte
die spd in meiner kindheit noch
interessiert beim parteitag hat jeder
zweite redner gesagt die spd muss sich
ich zitiere erneuern immer wieder wir
müssen uns erneuert ja wie denn immer
groko hier wir erklären euch nochmal
kindgerecht liebe kinder
die spd möchte in die groko und sich
erneuern geht leider gar nicht schade
denn da muss man sich entscheiden
entweder neu oder merkel neu werke
beides zusammen geht nicht und nächste
woche erkläre ich euch den unterschied
zwischen erfolg und schulz
klick für männer ab dem 8
pflege und verdient allerdings auf
krukow in obing yoko ono ist es auch
egal
sehen wir mal das positive das gehört
auch dazu in der spd gibt es wenigstens
debatten die union kennt sowas gar nicht
die cdu überhaupt eine basis ich weiß
nicht klar dass größere
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem das hat aktuell
die sozialdemokratie ja wegen dieses
wegen dieses ganzen hü und hott der
letzten monate und jetzt holen natürlich
die blöden schweine vom fernsehen die
ganzen alten zitate wieder raus wie zum
beispiel die wähler haben uns den platz
in der opposition zugewiesen wir nehmen
die verantwortung an und diejenigen
opposition das ist kein wähler auf tafel
der große koalition
es wird da auch keine hintertür geben
lieber neuwahlen als großer kulisse
haben keine große koalition machen ja
ich bin dagegen dass man also überhaupt
redet und da gibt's auch keine hintertür
wählerinnen und wähler haben einen
anspruch darauf dass politiker sagen was
sie tun und anschließend tun was sie
sagen
passend dazu eine meldung von heute nach
spiegel informationen will martin schulz
wohl nun doch als minister ins kabinett
merkel politikverdrossenheit mach mit
einer aktion der heute show
[Musik]
natürlich dich
politikverdrossenheit ist nicht die
lösung ganz im gegenteil genau jetzt
sage ich jetzt muss man in parteien
eintreten zum beispiel auch in die spd
glaube da gibt es bald einen
mitgliederentscheid habe ich gehört und
dann kann natürlich jeder abstimmen wie
er will
logisch also meine da mischen wir uns ja
nicht ein ist ein freies land ich finds
nur unfair dass jetzt so viel druck auf
die basis gemacht wird von der
parteiführung
da ist im grunde ihr müsst euch
entscheiden groko oder faschismus
umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus die afg
gibt es doch nur wegen der vielen groß